oh my god earthquake oh i
i has not hit la yet but i saw that
hey oh there's babe there's tarik hi
hi check out honeybunny thank you honey
oh my gosh all right love you look at
her hand
yes she said yes that's the future
well first of all congratulations hey
thank you so much i'm so excited and so
happy
it's kind of a nice uh note to go into
the season on because
i think people are gonna watch season
three and each episode be like is he
gonna propose are we gonna get a
proposal
are we gonna get a ring yes not on the
show get off the show
yet i think everyone was hoping it's so
funny to
know you're engaged and then see what's
on the show because
it seems like every episode you're just
talking about getting married
wanting a ring wanting to plan a
bachelorette party
from a wedding that's not happening yet
i know i'm not one of those people that
have thought about my wedding my whole
life but i'm so in love with tariq
and we knew from the very beginning like
we were gonna spend our lives together
we were gonna get married we went ring
shopping like three months into our
relationship so like
i knew it was coming i just didn't know
when but everyone else was like
do you think it's gonna happen there
here what do you think it's gonna happen
i'd be getting text messages is this
gonna happen in paris
and i'm like you guys i don't know but
then i start getting excited like well
maybe it will
but watching it back now i'm like thank
god he proposed because i look
dumb i always say how do you feel about
how you come off because you do look a
little like obsessed with love and
obsessed with tarik which i think you
are obsessed with clerk
and you are obsessed with being in love
with tauren yeah like i'm not
embarrassed about that like i love love
i found my soul mate i
want to spend the rest of my life with
him um obviously obviously it's not all
i talk about it's also edited
so you know it's a story and it's a
story line and
but yeah i talk about him all the time i
do talk about marrying him but
i did tell him because we watched it the
other night i was like wow thank god you
did it because i do talk about it a lot
but honestly like in our real life i'm
not out there talking really pressuring
him and like when's it gonna happen like
it's just a joke you know it was just
something fun
and like i'll hurry up hurry but it's
fun
you do say in the show that you think
he'll propose when you least expect it
so did you expect it at all when it
actually happened
i didn't and i didn't because he's very
romantic he likes to do special things
for
for me and because it was our one year
anniversary i knew that he had
special things planned throughout that
weekend and everything that we were
doing had a cover
so we were filming for flipping 101 but
it was for an episode that we have
coming out together
i think it's coming out in september so
he's like the crew is going to be here
filming a little b-roll of us
and they're going to add it on to our
episode i'm like okay that's fine it's
for work it's for his show like he'd do
it for me so of course
i'm okay with it so and i knew he had
surprises planned but i just thought it
was going to be like a really special
dinner
i didn't think it was going to be a
proposal so like in my mind i never like
sat and thought thought like oh it's
going to happen my friends did like a
few of my friends said something but i'm
like no i don't think he's going to do
it on our one year i think
he'll wait a few months so cameras were
rolling but they were not the selling
sunset cameras no
they were hdtv's cameras so you can
appear on his
show but he can't appear on your show
i'm allowed to appear on one episode for
his show
so um we shot most of our episode well
so i thought we shot our episode
it was already finished um i have a
client and targ helps my client
um flip her house flip a house so um he
brought
i brought her him on he brought me on to
kind of help each other um so then he
told me oh we're just filming because
his episodes are going to be an hour now
so he's like oh we're just adding on
to that episode um but yeah i'm only
allowed to film one episode with him
and he doesn't have that carve out for
himself to go beyond one episode of
selling sunset
you know we might have a special um
special announcement to make for
season four if we get season four
there's a possibility he might be
jumping on
okay because i was that would be my next
question it's it's a big deal
to get engaged and uh to not be able to
share any part of that on a show that's
about your life i know well that's hard
to because
so much of my life is tauric and i can
talk about him i think that's why i talk
about him so much
is because he is a huge part of my life
and he can't be on the show with me
so all i can do is talk about him right
and talk about our moments and talk
about
how much fun we have and everything
going on but um yeah
there might have been a deal made so
okay well that also makes me feel good
about you know
season four me too but honestly i don't
know about season four but i mean
fingers crossed
do you see yourself relocating to orange
county full-time
i am full-time yeah i moved full-time i
mean tark and i moved in together
like two weeks after we started dating
but um
you know we kept a place in la because i
was up there a lot for work and i still
do have to be up there a lot for work so
we're gonna figure that out when the
time comes but you know i love orange
county
i love being with the kids all the time
i love being with tarik all the time and
it does make it a lot harder the commute
is long as you know
but when we get to that bridge we're
gonna figure it out okay a post covered
bridge figure out what's your la light
exactly
exactly so season four we might get an
episode with tarek
having seen how mary's wedding went and
how christine's wedding went would you
want to film your wedding for the show
you know we have talked about this
obviously because he's on tv
i'm on tv and i
really i struggle with that one because
i'm
i also like this is it's going to be my
wedding day it's going to be very
personal and very special and
you know when you're filming you're
you're mic'd up there's certain
obviously when there's cameras on you
maybe people might act a different way
and my guest might feel a certain way
and
it might take that pers i don't know it
might take that
it might make it too impersonal so i
don't know yet we need to talk about it
we need to kind of weigh the
pros and cons and then make a decision
but i know that hgtv is going to want it
and the netflix will probably want it so
they're going to be battling for that
probably maybe there's some sort of a
deal that could be weirdly struck there
where it's like it goes on both
and they premiere at the same time and
you can watch whichever version you want
well the fact that they
they um we're able to like make a deal
with
engagement like i have some hope but you
know i don't know it's something dark
and i really need to talk about as a
couple and decide if we want to
invite the cameras into our special day
and
you know one day like it's only been a
week but i'm already like well you know
we're trying to come
plan the location and um plan certain
things and
i'll go back and forth i'm like maybe we
should do it here maybe we'll just a
load maybe we'll go to europe like i
don't know we're literally every day
it's something different
well because there's all those things
that in regular life you want to think
about like can we get cleared to film
here is there space for cameras in
here and all that kind of stuff yeah and
that's the thing venues have to approve
that and
and i don't know it's just something
that like that both their weddings were
beautiful and
ask them would they do it again would
they film it again if they had the
choice
or do they feel like it took away from
their their special day season three got
a lot more personal
than seasons one and two um does that
scare you at all about what you would
be asked to kind of share on the show i
think
it's our choice like they could always
ask and then i can either say yes or no
and it's a reality show so sometimes in
the moment
we do forget we're filming and as you
see like we talk openly about things and
um right when we get into the office or
we get on
on set wherever we're filming they mic
us right away so like sometimes us girls
are having conversations like real
conversations and i'll forget i might
i'm like
oh my god technically they can use
whatever they want you know like and not
that i'm thinking about like i might or
not mike but
you just forget the cameras are there
like this is our real lives and
um but i don't know i think when the
time comes it'll be a personal choice
i'll have to make but
i mean i think a lot of my life and
almost my whole life is out there
already so um you know that's kind of
the name of the game put my life out
there
yeah that's what you signed up for what
i signed up for and i think you know
season one
they were introducing us more and then
season two and three they got to really
go behind the scenes and get to know us
as real people